We can all learn, doesn't matter
what our age is, doesn't matter
what our presumed talent is.
We're constantly learning.
And the reason I raise this subject is
because someone commented here on my
YouTube channel, as an older person,
you have to learn like a stroke victim.
You have to use different
parts of the brain, et cetera.
Okay.
Older people, we now know they
retain their neuroplasticity.
Anytime you're learning something, you
are creating new pathways in the brain.
You are renewing your brain.
Today, for example, I've been
trying to set up my studio here.
It was a lot of work.
I had to learn a lot of new things.
And I'm not naturally patient when it
comes to doing things with my hands.
But I realize I have to be patient if
I'm going to set all these things up.
Three different sets of acoustic panels.
These sconces you see behind me.
Lots of work, but all the
while I'm conscious of forging
new habits in my brain.
That's what learning is all about.
And languages are the same way.
So it doesn't matter if as an older
person, it's harder for me, or maybe
it isn't, or maybe it is, or because
I have a lot of practice at learning.
I'm used to doing it.
It doesn't matter in learning a
language, we are enabling our brain
to form a model of another language.
We form that model through
repetitive exposure to the language.
Eventually we start to be able to
predict what's going to come at us,
which helps us in our comprehension.
It also helps us when we want to
express ourselves, we want to produce
an utterance based on the accumulated
experience that we have with the language.
But anything you're learning is
constantly forging new connections
in your brain, new synapses.
And so the idea that...
Some people don't have the ability that
their brains won't learn new things.
If I want to do it, if I stay with
it, if I continue, I will learn.
So the issue becomes more, how do
you encourage people to stay with it?
Well, one of the things is to make sure
people understand that they can learn.
The other is anything that
can nudge people forward.
So in my case, I went and
bought a, a little hand drill.
Well, now I got to use the hand drill
because I've got to drill the holes
to mount my acoustic pads on the wall.
So that kind of nudges me.
I can't give up on the project.
I've got to stay with it.
Or even, you know, something like in
the morning, I think there's a certain
discipline in doing my seven minute
exercise muscle booster, but sometimes I
don't really feel like doing it, but then
I'm nudged forward by saying I will go.
To, uh, Radio Fardo, download some Farsi,
the news of the day, and, and then I
import it into LingQ, the sound file.
So I get a transcript and the fact
that I'm going to be grabbing this
sound file from Radio Fardo nudges
me to do my morning exercises.
So there's a lot of
little things like that.
A person you met, a class, for
example, but we have to remember that
the way we're going to progress in
the language is if we can continue
to expose ourself to the language.
It almost doesn't matter
what you're able to produce.
It almost doesn't matter what you're able
to say and how many mistakes you make.
What matters is that you continue.
Forging these new pathways in your
brain, as I did today, putting all
these acoustic panels up on the wall.
It's not that I can hire myself out
as a handyman, but I feel that I
created some tolerance for frustration.
And so consistency, perseverance,
a few things that not just forward.
As long as we keep going,
anyone can learn, regardless
of age or presumed aptitude.
Before I leave you, I want to leave a
couple of videos for you to look at.
One on whether there is a talent for
language learning, and another on
whether age matters, or to what extent
age affects our ability to learn.
I think both of these videos are
relevant, so please have a look.